[Music]
welcome to everyone at Microsoft
Research for the second workshop which
is on issues of AI and society we've had
a first workshop in the past and and
part of the afternoon we'll be recapping
what happened the first time around the
major change from the first time was
that when we did it the first time it
was primarily people who were academics
who were and research research and and
practice who were part of the workshop
the one thing we did realize is that it
makes a big difference to do this with
people who are actively in the social
sector as you've all probably realized
AI and society is quite the buzzword
these days even resna Khan's latest film
is about artificial intelligence yeah
and so this is not just one more event
in that space what we are trying to do
is aggressively engage with problems
which are coming from the social sector
and look at how technologists can
partner with that so the format of the
day is that the first half which is talk
space is we start off with a talk from
the center director and from the the USC
folks and this is us C's is the driver
with MSR of this is this event and the
second half of the day will have
nonprofits and NGOs talking about some
of their problems that they'd like to
apply various data related solutions to
following which there will be breakout
sessions in which people will actually
get together in groups and talk about
what technology can do to solve some of
those problems so in another sense the
second part of the workshop is
essentially a working workshops if you
want to sneak away before that the time
is right after lunch so having said that
I am going to go ahead and let sridama
take it from yours the director of MSR
India and will introduce us to the thank
you thank you so much Georgie and
I want to thank all colleagues from USC
for and making this trip all the way
here and I'm doing this workshop
together with us
and I'm also very excited to welcome you
know all the NGOs and people from the
social sector as Georgie mentioned we
had a previous event but that one was
mostly academic in nature and I think I
really want to welcome all of you for
taking the time to come here and
participate in this conversation with
with all of us this is a picture of our
first floor if you haven't seen it you
should go upstairs
absolutely beautiful office we are
blessed to have I think I invite you to
go upstairs and check check check our
gig out I want so the object of my talk
is to give some context for who we are
and why we are doing this that's that's
my goal so that you have a sense for why
we are doing what we're doing to that
end actually I wanted to first introduce
Microsoft Research Microsoft Research is
was set up in 1991 and we are a global
organization we have four labs in the
United States one in the West Coast and
clean the East Coast we have one in the
UK one here in Bangalore and one in
China in Beijing and we we have more
than a thousand people 850 PhDs you know
with Rick Rasheed computes it as an
computer science departments with I
guess it is a 50/50 whatever that number
is that many computer science
departments and engineers and and
development horsepower could take those
ideas actually and transition them and
this is our mission and I think Rick
Rasheed was a big Star Trek fan so I
think this mission is somewhat modeled
around I guess this is to explore new
worlds civilizations did I think the
last one is to boldly go nowhere as gone
no man has gone before
and you know whatever so that that's
there you know you can see but it's
interesting and inspiring that the
mission is written in such a way that it
doesn't talk about Microsoft's current
products it gives us Microsoft research
the ability to to have as its first and
foremost goal to expand the
state-of-the-art which really drives the
culture of this organization this is us
this is Microsoft Research India we were
set up in 2005 so we
you just became a teenager I think we
are now 13 years old and we and this is
all of us you can fit us all in one
picture I always like to brag about my
colleagues said these are awards that
you know my colleagues have won recently
and a bill T's was a year before last he
was he wanted MacArthur prize we have
you know had three ACM fellows recently
Venkat also won the shanti swarup
bhatnagar price which is the one of the
highest awards that the indian
government offers to scientific research
and it is the first time they've given
it to someone who is not in an IIT or a
or a DRDO or a government organization
they gave it to someone working in a
multinational lab which is a real
testament to you know how people value
and respect what we do in Ronnie
recently won the secret Social Impact
Award that's the sense for the
colleagues that we have and this is our
younger crowd in addition to the
full-time people we have a program
called a research fellow program where
we recruit undergraduates people have
finished bachelor's and master's and we
recruited mice trainees research
trainees they spend one to two years
with us we currently have 40 research
fellows I think they me run the risk of
them exceeding the number of full-time
employees I think sometime soon we
actually started with five research for
us now we have 40 and for those 40
positions we get more than a thousand
applications and you know the best from
all the IITs and BITS Pilani and the tip
line is applied there and and they bring
so much energy
much like students bring in academia and
we have 40 of them currently here and so
one thing that happens is that a lot of
them go do phd's after they finish their
time here you know they could have light
USC or you know Berkeley and you know
they go to US universities European
universities but some of them decide not
do research and the ones that decide not
to do research tend to do better and so
all I was started by one of them by any
measure of imagination I think he's
doing well
you know capillary was started by
Krishna Mehra who was an RF with me and
these are other companies that have
started out of staff that live in the
lab that gives you a sense for how
entrepreneurial the lab is and and large
measure it is due to the young people
that the new talent that we get every
year this describes the work that we do
in this lab our work is organized on
four major areas we do a lot of work in
theory and foundations of computer
science mathematics behind machine
learning we have a very strong group
that does core machine learning and
artificial intelligence algorithms tools
implementations natural language
processing so we are very well
represented in those areas as well we
have a very strong group in systems
which is the foundations in
infrastructure based on which everything
is built and there is a very unique
group in this lab called technologies
for emerging markets which is which
study is the role of Technology in
socio-economic development and it is
most relevant to today's meeting and
this is an interdisciplinary group that
contains both computer scientists as
well as social scientists and a lot of
the work that I will talk about today
you know he's he's from this group but
increasingly the area of technology for
societal good is becoming very
interdisciplinary and people with
background in systems and machine
learning are also doing work in this
area so I would broadly represent work
from the entire lab in in this area
right so actually I also wanted to say
mention that as a lab we think about our
work having impact along three axis one
is in science we're advancing the state
of art in anything anything and
everything that we do and the second one
is company I mean there is a lot of
stuff that we do that gets transitioned
into either existing products or
inspires new products and services for
our company and and we explicitly
acknowledge in helping society as an
important part of the axis of impact
that we have so for the people that are
here from you know NGOs and social
enterprises one thing that I should make
very clear is that the work that we do
in this space is not CSR activity right
our company
ses our activity and then there is a
there is a law in India that 2% of every
company's revenue is given and we do
that too right but this workshop is not
about that this workshop is about as
engaging as scientists and technologies
with you to help you solve problems in
collaboration with us that's what this
workshop is about the other interesting
thing that has happened is that I joined
MSR about 19 years ago and when I joined
MSR Microsoft was a Windows and Office
company and so a lot of the work that we
did in impacting society was largely of
no relevance to the company it was not
relevant to the company's products but
if I now look at our cloud and AI
offerings right this is asthma is very
integral to whatever company does you
know we do want to engage with
government we want to engage with large
communities people understand what
problems they want to solve so it's very
much you know something that our company
commercially is actually interested in
as well and you'll see examples of that
in the slides that I'll show you next
right so here I have some examples of
the kind of things that this lab has
done in the past so I will start with
mature projects and projects that you
know have had the benefit of time and
and sort of see where they have gone now
the first one on the far left is a
project called IVR Junction that was
started by Bill T's and this is an
interactive voice response system so
that people in remote and communities
where people have access to a feature
phone but perhaps don't have the
literacy skills or they don't have a
smart phone to engage on social media
like Facebook or LinkedIn or Twitter but
nevertheless I think they have very
interesting is to say they have issues
like most of us you know just like you
know we get upset when we get a
defective product and we can flame on
Facebook they would like to do the same
thing as well so so IVR Junction was a
piece of infrastructure it was developed
by by Bill and and his colleagues and
then it was adopted by first by CG nets
whare which is an NGO that works in
Gondwana and they answer
NGOs in the world even I know that
Somali Somali land has actually adopted
it the you know you could go to the idea
junction webpage and you will see a huge
list of customers that are using it to
have four to have these people raise
their issues you know schools where
people teachers have not been paid have
that grievance has been addressed you
know there was a case of a hospital
which was only on paper but there was
actually no hospital at all so that has
been discovered so it's very powerful
and empowering to people who didn't have
wise before MEK is an online learning
experiment that we did in this lab which
we actually started something called
blended learning where we combined
online learning together within
classroom education and that was
actually picked up by our Development
Center in Hyderabad and it has now
evolved into project Sangam where the
online learning system is also being
integrated with LinkedIn and it is being
offered as a service for skilling and
job training for low-income labor so
it's very interesting something that we
didn't anticipate there would happen
when we originally started this project
digital green is a video enabled
agriculturally extension which was
started as a project in this lab and it
now advanced in tens of thousands of
villages both in India and in Africa
mm-hmm
ninety nine dots and I think Amy is here
so she will give an update on ninety
nine dots later is an innovative M
health platform for tuberculosis
medication adherence and this is a
project it was started here and now we
we spun it off into a startup called
ever well Andrew cross is the CEO of
ever well and it's right down the street
so I think if you have time you could go
visit ever well as well yeah so I wanted
to give you a sense for the current
projects that are going on in this lab
and my objective behind doing this is so
that you get a sense for the kind of
problems that our staff is interested in
right because the goal of this workshop
is to open collaborative conversations
between our staff and all of you so I
hope that these things give you the
sense for the kind of things that our
staff is interested in so let me go from
- right so the current worked in the lab
there is a lot of interest in work so
Korea for example is a project where we
are targeting Mechanical Turk like crowd
work for digital labor for transcription
for labeling for labeling text for
labeling date of speech so that
automated NLP can actually be enabled
for languages for which we don't have
any training data and we are working in
government to see if the people who do
this code work can actually be paid and
in a lot of cases the government is
actually willing to pay for such work so
Korea is such a project avatar is very
interesting it actually uses again code
work to do verification say you are an
NGO and you have donated money and
somebody has built a toilet how do you
know that the toilet has been actually
built so this one uses crowd sourcing to
have someone go there stream a video and
then verify the recall it has been built
and we could do this you know anything
we could pay make it my small micro
payment and we could do this
verification any number of times and so
that if there is something wrong we will
come to know about it right so that's
another one
cos Allah is a very interesting platform
that is actually being built by our
Development Center it is a little bit
like whatsapp but for enterprise so it
has a whatsapp like interface a chat
interface for the client but it also has
a server side where you know you can now
write server code to manage all the
information and so on it has it has an
enterprise component of chat as well and
and Jackie O'Neil has been working with
that group to sort of understand sort of
the social implications of how such a
product gets used by people and the
customers for this turns out to be under
previous government s CRP which turns
out to be society of for elimination of
rule and poverty right so the customers
of something like this turn turn out to
be field workers who do societal work
and send me engage with them sort of
understand both technical and
non-technical aspects of how such a
product should be built blend net is
another very interesting project where
we are trying to use bulk date
peer-to-peer connectivity to transfer
bulk data between mobiles
so thanks to Reliance Geo 2g 3G
connectivity is very prevalent in India
but it is still very hard to download or
upload bulk media like video is actually
always hard to do so blur net is uses
peer-to-peer connectivity for more bulk
data but still uses Azure as a network
in order to make sure that you can do
peer-to-peer without knowing the other
person so you don't have to know who the
other person is to get the video as your
knows who has what video and it'll
actually stands for that for you learn
to earn it's a very interesting system
where it uses micro payments and
incentives for people to transmit learn
information and transmit it to others so
it is actually a platform for virally
spreading information dissemination and
and there's more I'm not going to go
through more of these you know you
already mentioned 99 dots we have Amit
Sharma who's working on technology for
mental health issues this is a financial
inclusion we have a lot of work that is
going on around technology for
accessibility it's a core area of the
lab now and I want to show you a few
more so that national language
processing is also very important area
in this lab and you know since this
workshop is about AI and societal good I
should call out specifically that NLP
has a huge promise for bringing people
who have very low textual literacy and
and make the benefits of digital
technology accessible to this population
which is a huge population in India and
yeah I think has a huge amount of
promise in inclusion for serving these
kinds of communities but there are
significant technical challenges because
of simply the absence of annotated data
for lots and lots of these kinds of
languages so that's actually a topic
that we that we actively work on see
Kalika and monitored back in the
audience they study low resource
languages and they have an active
engagement going on with seed units
whare to make an AI and NLP work for
Gandhi which is a tribal language with
absolutely no annotations today IOT is
another area where we do a lot of work
we have work in Internet of Things
sensors for agriculture for for safety
you know how do you use sensors to make
sure that we can monitor drivers and
help them have safe driving behavior and
so on I mean if you're here you might
actually also get a demo of an
interactive cane I think you know
there's she she upstairs can give you a
demo and these projects are projects
where we are using blockchain those
kinds of technologies for decentralized
identity for making sure that there is
trust and transparency in what people do
I mean many of the NGOs might be
interested in technologies that can
ensure that you can actually crack where
your funds are going and so on so we
have technologies that are based on
blockchain to do and those kinds of
activities hopefully this gives you a
sense for the kind of work that this lab
does and you know please keep this in
mind so I'm not saying actually we will
engage with you only on these topics but
hopefully this give you a sense for
where people are coming from ok so I
wanted to show this slide as sort of a
meta slide of what we have learned over
the years doing all these projects I
know bead HealthBeat education and so on
so some points here are one of the
things we have so one of the things
about this lab is that I would say in
addition to writing papers and we
actually deploy what we've built here in
fact actually we write a paper when we
have something to say and a paper is
usually a byproduct of what we do rather
than something that we do because
there's a conference deadline right and
I mentioned this not to disparage
academics but to reflect on my own
experience as a student right because as
a student I do you have to do that
because that's only way you need to grab
you can graduate and as faculty right we
have to do that because you have to
graduate students so you know don't
don't don't don't take me wrong right so
I understand that but in the lab like
this right we have the luxury of you
know doing deployments learning from
them and only writing then we have
something to say right and so one other
thing that we have learned is as a
result of deployments in in in several
and underserved communities low resource
environments how important people are in
the socio-technical system that you have
to that you are designing we're
technology we repeatedly see you know
takes root only if it is an amplifier
and it amplifies people that those are
the only situations where a technology
he gets adopted and when we see this
time and again we see time again in when
we work with people with low literacy
when we work with people you know who
are were drivers all our drivers sort of
understanding you know what where they
are coming from is such an important
part of what we do so we have
ethnographers and so on who just immerse
themselves do these communities and
study what they do even before we even
decide what to do a project so that's
very much in the culture of the lab and
actually another thing that I'm very
proud about is the amount of effort that
goes into measurement and evaluation you
know doing things like randomized
control trials you know and now
increasingly using machine learning to
identify you know causal effects and so
on but we do like papers and a lot of
our work is also known in the academic
community for papers if you've written I
want to give an example of you know in
the in my so I showed you in Ronnie's
societal impact award I mean that came
because of about ten years of work that
she did you know thinking about
interface design for low literate
communities so that really presented
also a body of work that is identified
with that research except kentarou
Toyama who started the TM group he also
formed this conference called ICT d2
which was the first Avenue for a
publication of scholarly work in this
space and now I CTD has its 10th edition
is going to happen in am debarred
next year and there are other contents
like dev and I think the more recent one
and I think that million that others
have been also involved enjoy chicas in
Walden I think build pieces in Walden
so this lab has had a significant role
in getting these communities started and
we actively publish in these communities
as well right
I wanna mention quickly some other
things that we're doing more recently we
recently started an effort around a
societal impact incubator and the reason
why we did this was to reflect on our
experiences doing projects like ninety
nine dots which transitioned into ever
well digital green which transitioned
into an NGO so we have learned that it's
a journey and its journey is different
in each one of these projects to take
something that we cook up in a lab and
take it to the community and not only
take to the community make it
self-sustaining and survive outside the
lab right and have an ecosystem where
there is funding there's a business
model and there is people that will take
the idea on and the idea just survive
outside the lab and and you increasingly
realize how important that aspect of the
research that we do is so we decided
that we wanted to bring in it so we did
this call and I'll show you the call in
in the next page where we wanted to
bring in partners you know government
the social entrepreneurs to work with us
to participate in that part of the
journey and one of the reasons why we
did this was actually we also realized
that there are other parts of Microsoft
other than Microsoft research that are
very interested in this activity so we
are partnering with them to do this kind
of social societal impact incubator and
that's the web page and we had a call
for collaborative projects on cloud and
AI technology for social recital impact
and these were the themes that we put
out and interestingly if you see these
themes aligned with the projects that I
mentioned to you which is the work that
the people in the lab are doing and so
we put this out we thought you know
what's going to happen we receive I
think I don't know what the right number
is hundred and fifty one
175 yes so we thought maybe you will get
50 submissions we got hundred and 75 I
think now we got to go through the
process of evaluating them and we are
going to select like 4 5 something like
that and we're going to fund them and
every one of them is going to have
somebody in the lab to work with them
that's actually in some sense more
important than the funding itself that
we give and we sort of think about this
as the process of connecting with the
community which is so important for
these projects for them to survive
outside the lab right actually that
brings into point about why we are doing
this workshop the reason why we do calls
like this and this workshop is because
we are humble we realize that we cannot
do these things alone and the community
is such an important part of what we do
and there is something that we have
learned over the years and that's the
reason why we invite all of you the
final topic I'll touch upon is social
implications of AI and this is not true
just for AI every time you have new
technology could be automation could be
nuclear power I know
technology can cut both ways it can do
good it can do harm and any discussion
about technology and particularly I
think AI has to actually consider social
ethical implications of what we are
doing so so Jackie O'Neill pointed this
page to me and this is a very
interesting report that if you haven't
read I encourage reading it this is a
it's it's Institute in NYU called AI now
and they have a report there is AI now
2016 report and there's also an AI now
2017 report if studies you know it
brings out issues about labor and
automation and potential job loss from
AI how to think about that how do you
think about bias and inclusion which is
fairness which is very important when we
use training data to train machine
learning algorithms and you know whether
we are training them with a
representative data set that represents
all of us rather than you know make
certain segments of the population you
know lights and liberties particularly
about the use of AI technology by
government around surveillance and video
surveillance facial recognition issues
like that and more broadly around issues
around ethics and governance
I think that such such an important
topic to discuss I hope that you know
when you have your breakout sessions in
addition to discussing technology I hope
that you know we will also discuss these
topics integrally what are what we do
interestingly we have inside Microsoft
my my manager his name is Eric Horowitz
he is a big proponent of careful
consideration of AI and ethics and
society he's formed a committee called
the ether committee which consists of ya
ethics which stands for a it takes an
effects in engineering and research and
these are the subcommittee's there are
seven working groups that are actively
working inside Microsoft Research and
Microsoft around all these various
topics ranging from sensitive users bias
and fairness and interestingly there is
a coverage of these seven topics among
the five things that you saw in the I
now report you know for example I think
Ajay Kumar that milling knows I think
she had she's a co head of the group on
bias and fairness for example and so so
we have resources even inside Microsoft
to bring to bear on these kinds of
conversations and I encourage all of you
to make use of all of these resources in
this conversation so I'm almost about to
end I wanted to introduce you the
multidisciplinary team we have I realize
booth and I have forgotten your picture
sorry about that so you know so this is
I want to show this because so we have
social scientists we have computer
scientists we have developers we have
program managers we have a really
diverse team that works in this area and
these are research fellows who are
students who are spending time with us
and I think most of them are here in
this room and I think it over over time
I think you will have the opportunity to
interact with most of them this is the
schedule for today you know I I welcome
my colleagues from USC and all of you
from NGOs and social sector is going to
be talks by by several people as Georgi
mentioned we did this is the second
workshop we are organizing there was one
that we did last year at ISC
and
and and so it'll you know so one of the
things that we're doing this afternoon
is to have breakout sessions where you
know you engage with our staff to really
think about you know what concrete ideas
we might work on together so that's
actually very important outcome of this
workshop is to actually really you know
catalyze concrete ideas for
collaboration and we did this last time
and they're going to be updates for some
of the workshop some of the projects I
think have made progress ganesh is here
already connection obligation yeah it's
easier so he was there the last one and
I think this was discussed and I think
Ganesh and colleagues have made a lot of
progress on that project so they're
going to talk about that there's gonna
be also an update on ninety nine dots so
I I'm really looking forward to hearing
from from all of you on the problems
that that that that that that that you
are inspired by so that we can
collaborate so the afternoon there's
going to be breakout sessions where no
more problems are going to be discussed
and there's people from the government
that are giving talks this afternoon and
then there's going to be presentations
for the breakout sessions you know who
or as you're thinking about you you get
to give talks on I think that's pretty
much it
okay thank you Anna be that we welcome
the colleagues from USC next target
thank
[Applause]